the dietary recommendation to prioritize  carbohydrates produced a veritable  epidemic of obesity and diabetes  resulting in what has been deemed by  reliable researchers as one of the worst  Public Health disasters of all time  doing almost the entire Western  population to a lifetime of catastrophic  chronic health problems remember what  happened the last time the government  agencies applied their tender Mercy to  determining what the people they serve  should consume we were offered the much  vaunted food pyramid telling us to eat 6  to 11 servings of grains and  carbohydrates a day with protein and fat  at the Pinnacle something to be indulged  in with comparative Rarity that all  turned out to be wrong the food pyramid  was brought into being not least by the  U.S department of Agriculture that is  why marketers not scientists or  nutritionists with no shortage  whatsoever of Lobby efforts by those  whose products ended up being promoted